[موسيقى]
ونحييكم متابعينا الى نقاش الملف الثاني
قضيه احداث المنصه في مصر والتي تعود
واقعها لعام 2013 تقود الى حاله اوراق
ثمانيه من قياده الاخوان للمفتي لابدا
الراي الشرعي في حكم الاعدامه ومن ابرز
المحاليلين المرشد العام للاخوان محمد
بديع وكانت حددت المحكمه جلسه العشرين من
سبتمبر المقبل للنطقي في القضيه التي
يحاكم فيها 79 متهما من قيادات العناصر
جماعه الاخوان وفور صدور الحكم نشر الاخوه
بيانات تطالب المجتمع الدولي بالتدخل لوقف
تنفيذ تلك الاحكام حيث طالبت كل من جبهه
لندن وجبهه اسطنبول دولا وحكومات بالتدخل
لوقف المحاكمات واطلاق السراح عناصرها
ونذكر انه وفقا للماده 155 من الدستور
المصري مشاهدينا بانه في حاله صدور حكم
النهائي بالاعدام يحق لرئيس الدوله اصدار
قرار بالعفو عن العقوبه كليا او بتخفيف
الحكم فيها او بتاجيل النظر فيها يذكر
كذلك انه قبل سنتين كانت اصدرت محكمه
النقد المصريه حكما نهائيا باعدام اثني
عشره من قاده الجماعه في قضيه احداثي
رابعه ولكن لم ينفذ هذا الحكم حتى الان
لحاله اوراق ثمانيه من قيادي الاخوان الى
المفتي لادانتهم في قضيه احداث المنصه
التي تعود وقائعها لعام 2013
القياديون الثمانيه قاموا بتدبير تجمهر
اخر من اعتصام رابع العدويه بطريق النصر
وصولا للنصف التذكاري بالمنصه بغرض اتساع
مساحه الاعتصام وشل حركه المنطقه بالكامل
لمنع قوات الامن من فضل الاعتصام مستقبلًا
فضلا عن انهم امدوا باقي المتهمين من
المشاركين في التجمهور بالاسلحه الناريه
والذخائر والعبوات الحارقه كما وضعوا خططا
لباقي المتهمين 79 وحددوا دور كل منهم
نفهم اكثر هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من
القاهره اللواء الدكتور خالد عكاشه عضو
المجلس القومي لمكافحه الارهاب والتطرف
اهلا بك ومن القاهره كذلك منير اديب
الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه اهلا
بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع
لواء الدكتور خالد عكاشه دكتور حضرتك تعلم
بانه تنفيذ حكم الاعدام لا يحصل مباشره
بعد اعلان المحكمه الحكم وكذلك احاله
الاوراق الى المفتي هناك اجراءات عديده قد
تاخذ اشهر ولكن هل هذه الاجراءات يمكن ان
تاخذ سنتين كما اخذته اجراءات الحكم
السابق باحاله او باعلان حكم الاعدام على
12 متهم ام ان مصر بدات تتخذ السياسه
جديده في خصوص تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بالتاجيل
او بالالغاء بحكم الرئاسي
تحياتي لحضرتك يا استاذه نديم ولضيفي
العزيز استاذ منير والساده المشاهدين
جميعا يعني ربما هذا القياس له علاقه بعدد
القضايا المتهم بها قيادات جماعه الاخوان
يعني ربما
ارتات السلطات المصريه
ان يتم
المضي قدما في انهاء كافه القضايا
المتهمين فيها قيادات الاخوان ومنهم
المرشد العام
وعدد كبير من اعضاء مكتب الارشاد يعني
اعتقد التاجيل كان بسبب
وضوح الصوره اكثر كشف كافه الوقائع
والملابسات خاصه ونحن نتحدث عن قضيه اليوم
التي سقط فيها احد الضباط قتيلا وايضا 14
ضحيه مدنيه
ارتكب جماعه الاخوان او هذه الخليه الم في
قضيه اليوم التي صدر بها الاحاله
ارتكبوا جريمه القتل بحق هؤلاء بشكل مباشر
وتم اثبات هذه الوقائع وفق اقوال الشهود
وكاميرات المراقبه وغيرها من الادله
الماديه ربما هذا
ولكن حتى
قضيه رابعه من سنتين صدر كذلك حكم
بالاعدام ولكن لم ينفذ حتى الان حضرتك
تقول بانه ربما هذه القضيه اي قضيه المنصه
شهودها واضحين الوقائع واضحه ولكن ماذا عن
قضيه رابعه هل يمكن ان يصدر حكم بالاعدام
دون ان تكون هناك ادله نهائيه وواضحه
وصريحه وثابته
لا لا اقصد ذلك بالطبع حكم صدور حكم
الاعدام
وخضوع هؤلاء الى تحقيقات امتدت لهذا القدر
المدى الزمني الكبير هو نوع من انواع
التدقيق الامني والقضاء
وسلطات التحقيق بتاخذ وقتها بشكل كامل انا
اقصد ان المتهمين في القضيه الاولى التي
منذ سنتين البعض منهم هم متهمون ايضا في
قضيه اليوم ربما رات السلطات المصريه ان
تقوم بتاجيل تنفيذ حكم الاعدام من اجل
افساح المجال لكشف العديد من الوقائع
الاخرى التي
شابت هذه المرحله الزمنيه وهي عام 2013
خاصه ونحن نتحدث عن تداخل في الادوار عن
تكليفات صدرت من المرشد العام عن اداره
لكثير من اعمال العنف كان اعضاء مكتب
الارشاد متورطين فيها لذلك اظن ان التاجيل
جاء بسبب افساح المجال لكش المزيد من
الوقائع اسماء كذلك مثل ما نعم هناك اسماء
مثل ما قلت حضرتكم بينها صفحه حجازي محمد
البلتاجي وهي اسماء موجوده في قضيه المنصه
وكذلك في قضيه رابعه صحيح ولكن استاذ منير
لماذا في هذه المرحله كثر الحديث في داخل
المسرعا امكانيه ان يكون هناك قرار رئاسي
بالتاجيل او بعدم تطبيق حكم الاعدام ونعلم
بان الدستور المصري ينص في مادته المئه
وال 155 على ان الرئيس هو الموكل له
الوحيد امكانيه القيام بهكذا تعديلات اما
بالتاجيل او كذلك حتى
اعفاء المتهمين من تنفيذ الاعدام
نعم اهلا وسهلا بك يا استاذ ريم
وبضيفك الكريم سياده اللواء بكل مشاهدي
العربيه يعني اعتقد ان هذه السلطه هي بيد
الرئيس وفق القانون والدستور هو من حقه
يعني ان يصدق على الحكم ان يختار الوقت
الذي ينفذ فيه هذا الحكم وبالتالي تصديقه
يعطي اشاره الى النيابه العامه ومن ثم
مصلحه سجون تقوم
بتنفيذ هذا وهذا شك فيه عرضناه ولكن هل
يفعلها هو السؤال هل يفعلها وما السبب
ولماذا هل بسبب الضغوط لانه
اسطنبول ولندن
مجموعات الاخوان هناك طلبوا دول وحكومات
بذلك هل هناك اسباب في داخل المصري لان
سؤال مطروح هل يفعلها السيسي ويتدخل في
مثل هكذا الظروف ولماذا
نعم يعني دعيني اخذ مما قاله سياده اللواء
يعني هذه القضيه على وجه التحديد قتل فيها
الضابط الشريف السباعي وهو كان يعمل
بالاداره العامه للامن المركزي وقتل فيها
ايضا مدنيين اذا انت تتحدثين عن اشخاص
قتلوا سواء كانوا ضباطا او حتى
مدنيين وبالتالي جرائم القتل والارهاب لا
اعتقد ان الدوله تتسامح معها لانه في
النهايه يبقى ان هناك دماء
وسيلت واوريقت من قبل الاخوان او من قبل
هذه الخليه فضلا على ان الدوله كانت وما
زالت وسوف تظل
تتعامل مع قضايا الارهاب والتطرف بحزم
وبقوه كل من صدر بحقهم احكاما نهائيه
وباته بالاعدام فيما يتعلق على سبيل
المثال بعد العام 2013 واعتقد ان هناك
اسماء كثيره
نفذ فيها احكام الاعدام على سبيل المثال
شباب الاخوان الذين شاركوا خططوا ودبروا
ونفذوا عمليه اغتيال النائب العام وهم
كانوا تابعين لحركه ما يسمى سواعد مصر حسم
نفذ فيهم حكم الاعدام واعتقد ايضا هناك
اشخاص اخرين كانوا محسوبون على طيارات
اكثر تطرفا مثل داعش ايضا تم تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام فيهم هناك اسماء اخرى
وشخصيات اخرى ربما اشتركت في تنفيذ عمليات
مسلحه في التسعينيات من القرن الماضي نفذ
فيهم جميعا
الاحكام وتم التصديق على هذه الاحكام حتى
صدرت ما يسمى
بالمبادرات الفكريه والفقيه في العام 1997
وعندما اعيد
اعيدت محاكمه بعضهم
وتم التعامل معهم خاصه وان هذه الاحكام
خففت من قبل القضاء اما وان القضاء اصدر
حكما نهائيا وباتا في قضايا تتعلق بالعنف
وقتل فيها ضباط ومدنيين اعتقد سوف ينفذ
فيهم الحكم قولا واحدا نحن نتحدث عن توقيت
تنفيذ هذا الحكم وهذا هو بيد السلطه
التنفيذيه بيد رئيس الجمهوريه هو الذي
يقتار الوقت الذي ينفذ فيه
والعلي استشهد بنقطه بسيطه يعني انت
تتحدثين نعم تتحدثين عن اسامه ياسين محمد
البلتاجي على سبيل المثال وصفوت حجازي صدر
عليهم حكم بالاعدام في نعم نعم صدر عليهم
حكم بالاعدام في يونيو من العام 2021 وهم
متهمون ايضا في هذه القضيه التي يتحدث
فيها الان اعتقد ان التحقيق معهم وما
يدلون به من معلومات اعتقد سوف يكون مفيدا
للمحكمه لو نفذ عليهم حكم الاعدام في
العام 2021 وهو قد صدر بحقهم احكام نهائيه
وباته بالاعدام اعتقد ان ذلك ربما لا يكون
مفيدا في التحقيق في هذه القضيه التي صدر
عليهم ايضا فيها حكما بالاعدام دكتور خالد
اسمح لي ان اسال لانه سالنا من وجهه النظر
القانونيه وكذلك السياسيه ولكن اسمح لي ان
اسال من وجهه نظر متابعه الشارع المصري
لمثل هكذا قضيه البعض
يقارب بين محمد بديع والحكم بالاعدام
وامكانيه تنفيذ الحكم عليه وبين حكم
الاعدام وتنفيذ حكم الاعدام على سيد قطب
وقيل وحضرتك اكيد قرات مثل هكذا التعليقات
قيل بانه سيد قطب لما نفذ في حقه حكم
الاعدام لم تقرا كتبه ولم تباع كما بيعت
من قبل
وكانه اعطاه تنفيذ حكم الاعدام رمزيه نحن
اليوم نتحدث عن مرشد الاخوان الذي صدر في
حقه حكم الاحدى الاعدام هل هناك حساسيه في
التعاطي مع مثل هكذا اسماء ان نفذ حكم
الاعدام فيها او بحقها
يعني لا اظن ان المقاربه ما بين سيد قطب
وعصره كنا نتحدث عن ستينات القرن الماضي
يمكن مقارنته بمحمد بديع سيد قطب ربما لم
يحظى بهذه التغطيه
الاعلاميه الكبيره التي فضحت وكشفت هذا
الحجم الكبير من التورط في ارتكاب العنف
وازهاق الارواح والقتل
وتنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه بتفجيرات وبتكليفات
وبضخ اموال داخل
شرايين هذه الخلايا وهذه التنظيمات التي
انبسطت من
رحم هذه الجماعه وبموافقه مباشره من محمد
بديع لذلك لا اظن ان هناك حساسيه ما حول
ان يتحول محمد بديع الى بطل لكن ربما هذه
نقطه تعدنا مره اخرى الى مساله تاجيل بعض
من احكام الاعدام المقصود هنا هو مزيد من
كشف هذه الاسرار وهذه الملابسات التي
تورطت فيها هذه الجماعه وكانت السلطات
المصريه ربما تواجه ضغطا كبيرا من الراي
العام المصري الذي كان بعد العمل 2013
يريد ان تقوم السلطات القضائيه باصدار
احكام
اعدام جماعيه بحق هؤلاء نظرا لانكشاف
جماعه الاخوان في مساله ارتكابها للعنف
ولكن النظام اصر ان تكون المحاكمات وفق
قواعد القانون وان ياخذ هؤلاء جميع حقوقهم
القانونيه من درجات تقاضي من
محاكم عاديه وايضا ان يكون لهم حق المثول
امام محكمه النقد كل هذه الامور كان هناك
تحفظ من الراي العام ان المساحات الزمنيه
طالت في هذه المحاكمات لكن كان النظام
المصري والنظ القضائي كان يريد ان يكون
للامر
النسق القانوني المنضبط وفي نفس الوقت ان
يساهم في عمليات الكشف عن المزيد من اعمال
التورط والانتهاك الكبير الذي قامت به
جماعه الاخوان بانها انزلقت سريعا بقدميها
منذ ثوره 30 يونيو
لكي تصبح تنظيما ارهابيا صريحا من خلال
تاسيس تنظيمات ارهابيه من خلال ارتكاب او
اداره مكتب الارشاد لمنظومه متكامله من
الاعمال الارهابيه ومن اعمال العنف والقتل
بحق المواطنين بل وتدمير
المنشات الدينيه مثل ما حدث في محافظه
المنيا واسيوط وهناك قضيه متهم فيها هؤلاء
بذلك كل هذه المنظومه اظنها تسحب البساط
من امكانيه ان يتحول محمد بديع الى رمزا
الى ايقونه ما في المستقبل وحضرتك تقول
بانه حتى هذه المقاربه لا تجوز بين سيد
قطب ومحمد بديع تحدثنا منذ قليل استاذ
منير عن جبهتي اسطنبول ولندن وحضرتك تعلم
بانه
الجبهتين نشرتا بعض التقارير التي حاولت
من خلالها ان يعني تتوجه للحكومات
للمنظمات لبعض الدول
للتاثير على ادخل المصري هل تعتقد بانه
تاثير خارجي يمكن ان يكون او يلقي بضلاله
على القرارات النهائيه فدخل مصر نتحدث على
قرار الرئيس السيسي ام ان هذا الموضوع لا
يناقش بتاتا في مصر
موضوع تطبيق الاعدام في حق هؤلاء يعني
اعتقد ان الدوله المصريه حازمه في مواجهه
جامعات العنف والتطرف ويتعاملت بقوه مع
هذا الملف القاهره تعتقد انها لا تواجه
فقط حركه الاخوان المسلمين وانما لديها
استراتيجيه لمواجهه كل جماعات العنف
والتطرف هي تتعامل وفق هذه الاستراتيجيه
وتتعامل على ان هذا التنظيم يمثل خطرا ليس
فقط على ان القوم المصري وانما انجاز
التعبير على الامن القومي الانساني هؤلاء
يشكلون خطرا على دول المنطقه وايضا كل دول
العالم وبالتالي لن يكون هناك تاثير يؤتي
بنتائج اذا ما مورست ضغوط من دول قريبه
على مصر مصر سوف تتعامل مع هذا الملف
لانها تسعى الى تفكيك هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه وتسعى ايضا الى تفكيك ولكنك
الان ولكنك الان تنهي بس سؤال كبير في
الواقع لما تقول بانه تنفيذ حكم الاعدامات
تسعى من خلاله مصر الى تفكيك هذه
المجموعات نحن نسال هل يمكن لتنفيذ حكم
الاعدام ان يفكك هذه المجموعات سؤال اخر
وكبير ربما نناقشه ولكن في نشره اخرى وفي
حلقات اخرى اود شكركم جزيلا شكر من
القاهره اللواء الدكتور خالد عكاشه عضو
المجلس القومي لمكافحه الارهاب والتطرف
والاستاذ منير اديب الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه شكرا لكم السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات